le ghb vous en avez sûrement entendu
parler il est utilisé par des agresseurs
pour obtenir ce qu'on appelle une
soumission chimique et pour dépouiller
pour frapper pour enlever ou le plus
souvent pour violer leurs victimes des
femmes dans l'immense majorité des cas
c'est ce qui vaut au ghb son nom de
drogue du violeur mais c'est quoi
exactement et surtout qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire on voit ça tout de suite avec
dix trucs à savoir sur le ghb mais pas
seulement car les copains
[Musique]
le ghb c'est quoi j'ai hbc les initiales
pour acide gamma hydroxybutyrate notre
corps il en produit en toutes petites
quantités mais c'est aussi un médicament
dans les années 60 il était utilisé
comme anesthésiant puis pour soigner
certains troubles du sommeil notamment
mais dès les années 80 il a commencé à
être détournés pourraient être utilisés
de manière récréative c'est à dire comme
une drogue c'est la raison pour laquelle
il a été mis sur la liste des produits
stupéfiants illicites mais faut savoir
qu'il ya aussi le gbl qui est un solvant
industriel et qui se transforme en ghb
une fois qu'il est dans notre organisme
à quoi ça ressemble le ghb il existe
sous plusieurs formes mais généralement
dans les cas de soumission chimique
c'est la forme buvable qui est utilisée
c'est un liquide qui n'a ni couleur ni
odeur donc ça se voit pas si on vous en
mets dans votre verre avant ça il ya
d'autres médicaments comme le rivotril
ou le rohypnol par exemple qui avait été
détourné pour la même utilisation les
laboratoires avaient fini par changer
leur couleur pour qu'on repère plus
facilement si on nous en avait mis dans
notre verre mais bon s'il était mis dans
une boisson colorés ou sombre s'assoyait
pas donc ça pouvait passer quand même
inaperçu
quel goût ça là le ghb ça a quasiment
pas de goût ça peut être légèrement
salée mais ça sent très peu surtout
qu'en général les agresseurs le verse
dans une boisson qui a suffisamment de
goût pour qu'on le sente pas du tout
commence à agir sur le corps
c'est un produit de synthèse qui a été
créé pour ressembler à un euro
modulateurs naturellement présent dans
notre corps à très faible dose le ghb il
va se fixer sur les récepteurs habitués
à le recevoir mais à des doses beaucoup
plus élevé et ça ça a deux conséquences
la libération de dopamine puis un
ralentissement général de l'activité de
tous les neurones concernés c'est ce
qu'explique l'euphorie la désinhibition
la perte de contrôle physique et mentale
voire l'amnésie est mélangé à de
l'alcool les effets sont multipliés
est-ce que ça agit vite
oui ça j'évite la montée elle est très
rapide en quelques minutes seulement
c'est même un moyen de faire la
différence avec les effets de l'alcool
par exemple à ce que vous allez voir que
c'est pas si simple est-ce que c'est
nouveau bah non c'est pas nouveau on
estime que le ghb était déjà utilisé
pour la soumission chimique et des viols
dans les années 90 et l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament a
lancé une première enquête et une
surveillance sur le sujet dans les
années 2000 et non seulement c'est pas
nouveau mais c'est pas le produit le
plus utilisé pour la soumission chimique
ce qu'on retrouve le plus souvent dans
ces cas là c'est des anciens olitique ou
des somnifères et plein d'autres
substances comme la mdm a par exemple
pour le moment c'est difficile de savoir
s'il ya plus de cas de soumission
chimique au ghb en ce moment où s'il ya
plus de signalements parce que la parole
se libère mais en vrai peu importe le
plus important c'est de savoir ce qu'il
faut faire dans ces cas là quel que soit
le produit
comment savoir si on nous en a fait
prendre à notre insu le problème c'est
que les signes ressemblent beaucoup à
ceux de l'alcool donc dans un contexte
festif ça peut être difficile de faire
la différence en gros on est ralenti on
gère mal ses mouvements on perd
l'équilibré on est euphorique on a des
réactions inhabituelles on peut avoir
des bouffées de chaleur la tête qui
tourne des nausées voire des
vomissements et on peut aussi avoir des
pertes de mémoire mais ce n'est pas
systématique vous voyez ça ressemble
quand même pas mal à quelqu'un qui est
bourré alors qu'est ce qui doit nous
faire penser à la soumission chimique
que ce soit au ghb ou à quoi que ce soit
d'autre d'abord il ya une incohérence
entre la quantité d'alcool consommée et
l'état de la personne si elle a juste vu
un cocktail et qui avait du mal à tenir
debout c'est qu'il ya un truc ensuite la
rapidité avec laquelle les signes arrive
c'est beaucoup plus rapide avec le ghb
ou les autres médicaments qu'avec
l'alcool seul et puis les comportements
inhabituels ça peut aussi mettre la puce
à l'oreille le côté je l'avais jamais vu
comme ça avant après le seul moyen
d'être sûr c'est de faire des analyses
mais ça on va en reparler retenez juste
un truc si vous avez un doute pour vous
même ou pour quelqu'un d'autre partez du
principe ya un problème vaut mieux être
trop prudent que de laisser un drap
marié qu'est ce qu'il faut faire si on
pense que quelqu'un a été droguée si
vous pensez qu'on a mis un truc dans
votre verre ou qu'on voulait a injecté
parce que ça revient au même bref si
vous commencez à vous sentir mal votre
premier réflexe ça risque d'être deux
isolé c'est humain c'est comme ça mais
en réalité il faut faire l'inversé
demander de l'aide à une personne de
confiance qui va s'occuper de vous et
ouais parce que comme on l'a vu dans ces
cas là la victime elle peut pas gérer
tout seul donc c'est hyper important
d'être vigilant sur l'état des gens
autour de soi si votre pote a pas l'air
bien la première chose à faire c'est de
rester avec elle parce que la soumission
chimique c'est juste la première étape
la personne qui a fait ça elle est dans
le coin et son but c'est pas juste de
drogués quelqu'un à son insu c'est de
l'agresser
donc on ne lâche pas la victime d'une
semelle on reste avec elle et on en
profite pour la rassurer en attendant
les secours oui parce que il faut
appeler les secours et là je parle du
samu le quinze des pompiers le 18 ou du
numéro d'appel d'urgence européen le 112
d'abord parce que laisser la personne
rentrer chez elles même temps leurs
accompagnants c'est dangereux que ce
soit avec le ghb ou quoique ce soit
d'autre le risque c'est que son état
s'aggrave et tombe dans le coma par
exemple ou qu'elle fasse des convulsions
d'ailleurs si la paire connaissance
pendant que vous êtes là mettez là on
pls et surveiller sa respiration bref il
va falloir qu'elles soient surveillés à
l'hôpital et la deuxième raison c'est
que le ghb pour garder cet exemple là
c'est détectable pendant moins de six
heures dans le sens et moins de 12
heures dans les urines donc si vous
attendez le lendemain ça risque d'être
trop tard
il ya aussi d'autres trucs importants à
faire à l'hôpital mais on va revenir
dessus dans le pointures on fait quoi si
on se réveille le lendemain et qu'on a
un doute si vous vous réveillez le
lendemain et que vous sentez qu'il ya un
truc encore une fois dans le doute il
vaut mieux agir et c'est pas trop tard
pour le faire mais d'abord peut-être que
physiquement et psychologiquement vous
allez avoir besoin de soutien donc
n'hésitez pas à appeler une personne de
confiance pour vous accompagner ensuite
il ya plusieurs numéros que vous pouvez
appeler vous avez des liens dans la
description mais ça semble assez
pertinent d'appeler le centre
d'addictovigilance c'est des gens qui
sont formés qui connaissent ce genre de
problématique et surtout qu'ils vont
vous donner les adresses où aller pour
être prises en charge dans les
meilleures conditions et dans un autre
registre ça leur permet de recenser les
cas de soumission chimique et les
endroits où ça se passe alors ensuite
qu'est ce qui va se passer au téléphone
on va sûrement vous conseiller et porter
plainte même si vous n'êtes pas sûr de
ce qui s'est passé
évidemment attention c'est à vous de
voir c'est votre décision
un truc à savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ya un certain nombre de choses qui sont
accessibles qu'aux personnes qui ont
porté plainte comme les urgences
médico-judiciaires par exemple ou le
remboursement des analyses sur les
cheveux qui est hyper cher en attendant
que ça change voilà sachez le mais
encore une fois au final le choix c'est
le vôtre donc on est lendemain qu'est ce
qu'il reste à faire d'abord les analyses
parce que même si le ghb disparaît vite
on a vu que c'était loin d'être le truc
le plus utilisé et les autres substances
elles peuvent rester détectable trois
jours en moyenne il de toute façon par
la suite pour en avoir le coeur net pour
le ghb on pourra faire des analyses sur
les cheveux les cheveux ils peuvent
révéler les substances qu'on a prise
mais bon à ce moment là il faudra
attendre un mois que le cheveu est assez
poussé pour que le bout qui correspond à
la soirée soit analysable et pendant ce
temps faudra pas se faire de
décoloration ni d'un tueur ni se couper
les cheveux sinon ça fausse le test mais
bon on n'en est pas là là tout de suite
il ya autre chose de super important à
faire à l'hôpital et pour laquelle il
n'y a pas trop de temps à perdre non
plus c'est la prise en charge d'une
éventuelle agression sexuelle dont la
victime peut ne pas se souvenir les
médecins ils vont chercher à déterminer
s'il ya des signes physiques il peut ne
pas y en avoir mais ils vont rechercher
éventuellement ils peuvent faire des
prélèvements adn mais aussi ils vont
proposer une contraception d'urgence
genre pilule du lendemain est aussi un
traitement post exposition au vih et
tout ça c'est important c'est quoi les
solutions pour éviter que ça arrive
alors vous allez trouver tout un tas de
trucs pour limiter les risques genre les
capotes avère le vernis à ongles qui
réagit à la présence de ghb dans les
boissons etc mais bon déjà c'est pas
l'assurance tout risque notamment parce
que comme on l'a vu le ghb ça n'est
qu'un des produits utilisés par les
agresseurs l'idée c'est d'être attentifs
les uns aux autres et de ne pas laisser
son verre sans surveillance genre si
vous devez sortir et que vous pouvez pas
le prendre avec vous finissez le avant
ou laissez le à l'intérieur mais le
reprenez pas en rentrant et puis si on
vous offre un verre ne l'accepté que
s'il a été servi devant vous alors
attention être vigilant c'est bien mais
faut pas non plus tout laisser peser sur
les victimes potentielles faut que les
autorités prennent des mesures les bars
et les boîtes aussi en faisant de la
prévention en formant le personnel en
améliorant la surveillance etc il ya
plein de choses à faire en attendant la
seule vraie solution que les hommes
arrêtent de violer alors tout ce qu'on
s'est dit là c'est valable dans tous les
cas de suspicion de soumission chimique
quelle que soit la substance utilisée
mais attention d'abord ça n'arrive pas
que dans les bars ça arrive aussi dans
un cadre privé et puis surtout tout ça
c'est aussi valable si une personne a
été agressée ou pense l'avoir été après
avoir pris volontairement des produits
dans ces gars là on appelle ça de la
vulnérabilité chimiques et non seulement
les risques c'est les mêmes mais profité
de la vulnérabilité d'une personne pour
avoir des relations sexuelles avec elle
qu'elle ait pris des trucs
volontairement ou pas ça s'appelle un
viol voilà dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]